bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
cette édition la ferme de bbas propose
samedi 22 mars une journée entière de
spectacle consacré à la poésie d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui Johann lavab directeur et
programmateur nous donne tous les
détails dans quelques instants samedi 29
mars la batterie à guyancour reçoit la
chanteuse ganzadi dans le cadre d'un
cabaret politique suivi d'un concert
Nicolas Gervet nous la présente France
Miniature organisé dimanche dernier une
animation autour de la maquette arien 5
en présence d'un expert de l'industrie
spacial nous reviendrons sur cet
après-midi de découverte de
l'espace jusqu'au 23 mars se déroule le
printemps de des poètes cette
manifestation nationale et
internationale a pour vocation de
sensibiliser à la poésie sous toutes ses
formes pour sa 16e édition le Printemps
des Poètes décline le thème au cœur des
arts thème choisi pour souligner le fait
que la poésie est souvent associée à
d'autres formes de création tel que le
chant la danse ou encore le théâtre à
5tin Yveline de nombreux événements sont
organisés en partenariat avec la maison
de la poésie et c'est le cas notamment
au Théâtre de guillancour la ferme de
bellba qui propose donc samedi 22 mars
une journée entière de spectacles où
bien entendu la poésie est à l'honneur
bonsoir yanaavre bonsoir vous êtes
directeur de la ferme de Bel ETB alors
peut-être déjà pour commencer vous
pouvez nous repréciser le principe de
cette journée C spectacles comment ça se
déroule oui oui c'est c'est une une
grande journée thématique donc celle-ci
est consacrée à la poésie et l'idée
c'est que le le spectateur va grandir au
fil des heures on va commencer le matin
avec des spectacles pour les tout petits
à partir de 1 an alors justement c'est à
11h he le premier SP c'est à 11h oui on
essaie vraiment de de caler l'heure en
fonction de de l'âge de l'âge des
spectateur donc le matin c'est vraiment
le le meilleur moment pour les pour les
très jeunes spectateurs 1 an 1 an 2 ans
3 ans mais jusqu'à 5 6 ans il y a pas de
souci et le spectacle s'appelle
bruissement c'est bruissement c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on y découvre alors c'est
un spectacle voilà pour cet âgelà c'est
très très sensoriel il y a un arbre sur
scène un arbre sonore et il y a deux
deux comédiennes musiciennes qui qui
chantent qui qui murmurent qui voilà qui
c'est un éveil au sens en quelque s oui
c'est ça il y a vraiment au son au son
mais également enfin c'est c'est très
visuel c'est c'est très chanté très
chantonné un très joli spectacle voilà
pour les pour les tout petits ça peut
être l'occasion de de fréquenter une
salle de spectacle pour la première fois
de sa vie effectivement alors à 14h ce
sera allons enfants de la poésie alors
là c'est un spectacle dans lesquels sont
chanter et accompagn en musique un
florilège de poème et donc de poète oui
bah lesquel voilà alors c'est un
florilège de de de poème sur le thème de
l'enfance donc c'est c'est Fabi Lucienne
pardon des chants qui qui orchestre tout
ça et on entendra des poètes des poètes
vivants des poètes d'aujourd'hui il y
aura un petit peu de texte de Jacques
Prévert mais surtout Bruno douset David
gumortier et évidemment Roland nado
qu'on ne présente plus à 5qu en é ah bah
on va quand même un petit clin d'œil à
Roland nado donc ancien maire de Guillan
courour fondateur de la maison de la
poésie et de la ferme de belb absolument
alors donc tous ces ces poèmes donc
seront lu ou chanté par de des jeunes
des ados qui viennent je crois du Club
des Jeunes théâtre et poésie oui alors
Lucienne Deschamps a invité
effectivement avec la Maison de la
poésie de saqutin en Yveline ce club
théâtre et poésie et voilà et quelques
quelques jeunes collégiens vont vont
rentrer à l'intérieur du spectacle et y
participer VO alors dès 16h on pourra
retrouver alors cette fois-ci ce sont
les Fables de La Fontaine mis en musique
alors dans le style de l'époque
c'est-à-dire la musique baroque
absolument c'est un spectacle proposé
par Amal Alaoui qui est une une
chanteuse lyrique spécialisée dans dans
dans le registre baroque et donc elle
vient avec un clavciniste une gambiste
donc qui joue de la viole de gambe et
elle-même chante et joue de la flute à
bec et donc c'est une plongée dans
l'univers musical de Jean de La Fontaine
et on entendra donc les les fables les
fameuses fables qu'on qu'on connaît tous
qu'on apprend à l'école alors du coup ou
oui voilà alors le le corbeau et le
renard voilà toutes ces fables qu'on
connaît très bien et on les entendra
mises en musique par des compositeurs de
l'époque de Jean de La Fontaine euh
voilà donc certaines fables seront
déclamées dans le style baroque ça peut
être un petit peu déroutant mais c'est
intéressant de montrer une œuvre un
petit peu dans dans son contexte
d'autres sont chantés et puis
progressivement le spectacle se se
décale un petit peu et on arrive vers
quelque chose de plus contemporain une
manière peut-être plus actuelle de dire
les textes une sorte de de métamorphose
en fait du spectacle absolument alors la
poésie c'est vrai que tous les publics
n'y adhèrent pas forcément est-ce que le
fait que ce soit en musique ça la rend
plus accessible bah c'est vrai que
beaucoup de gens on ont peur de la
poésie beaucoup de gens ont l'impression
que la poésie ne s'adresse pas à eux
c'est un peu élitiste parfois ou ben moi
je crois que les gens ont tort d'avoir
peur de la poésie je crois que surtout
que la poésie est très vivante et elle
mort pas donc faut pas avoir peur on
peut s'en
approcher vraiment je crois que les
poètes s'adressent s'adressent au plus
grand nombre même si le plus grand
nombre s'en méfie mais c'est vraiment à
tort alors c'est vrai que la musique euh
la musique permet peut-être une approche
un petit peu plus facile un petit peu
plus ludique on va dire que les sons
portent les sons des musiciens portent
les mots des poètes et souvent les
chanteurs les ont permis de vulgariser
des des grands poètes brassins voilà on
souvient brassince qui chante François
Villon Riani qui
chante qui chante Prévert ou ferra qui
chante Aragon effectivement voilà mais
voilà ça permet ça permet peut-être une
approche plus facile
d'une discipline qui fait peur mais qui
pourtant ne devrait vraiment pas
effrayer les gens et puis cette cette
journée à la fois poésie et musique ça
permet aussi peut-être de fédérer
c'estàdire que les gens qui viennent
pour la musique et puis d'autres gens
qui viendront pour la poésie absolument
oui oui oui ça peut être voilà ça
multiplie les portes d'entrée on va dire
ouais alors à 20h et 20h15 précisément
et 22h30 alors là ce sont des photos qui
seront projeté plutôt pour un public un
peu plus grand là maintenant on est
presque dans les adultes même on va dire
est dans les on est dans lesadit
disonsle carrément ce sont des photos
érotiquessolument Johann j'ai envie de
vous dire à quoi ça rime pour reprendre
le titre de de cette journée poésieque
alors c'est une rencontre c'est la
rencontre qu'on a provoqué sur un tout
autre pour un tout autre projet entre un
poète Dominique spierot qui était en
résidence d'écrivain soutenu par la
Région île-de-fance à la ferme de bbas
pendant pendant une année et un
photographe Ernesto Timor alors je les
ai fait se rencontrer tous les deux pour
un projet très par particulier qui était
pas du tout celui-là autour des des 40
ans du pont du routtoir à guillancour et
puis bah voilà quand mes deux artistes
en contact ça fait parfois des
étincelles et Dominique santpierot a
découvert une série de photographies
érotiqu d'Ernesto Timor et il a souhaité
écrire un un long poème sur ses photos
et donc voilà on va assister à la
projection des photos et à la lecture
des poèmes c'est Dominique sintpierron
lui-même qui sera présent non non non
c'est une comédienne Céline Livier qui
qui vient qui vient les lire euh voilà
Dominique sera là Ernesto aussi et voilà
ce qui donc ça se passe c'est pour un un
petit public une quinzaine de personnes
à la fois pas plus et on va emmener les
gens dans les loges à un endroit où ils
ont pas l'habitude d'aller dans les
loges du théâtre voilà et sur le sur le
dans les couloirs il y aura quelques
quelques photos d'Ernesto également et
en petit comité de manière très
confidentielle avant et après le dernier
spectacle de la so ça dure une quinzaine
de minutes absolument et c'est à partir
de 16 ans 18 ans voilà pas et alors le
dernier spectacle qui clôure donc cette
journée c'est un hommage musical et
poétique à la Grèce le spectacle
s'intitule et les rêves prendront leur
revanche avec entre autres angélique
yonatos qui est grande angélique yonatos
dites-nous un petit peu de de quoi il
s'agit mais voilà angélique yonatos he
donc une grand grande chanteuse grecque
qui a mis en musique les plus grands
poètes grecs du du 20e siècle à concocté
un récital où
elle où elle aborde un peu la voilà
cette situation si douloureuse de de la
Grèce aujourd'hui et c'est c'est une une
volonté de renouer avec l'utopie de
renouer avec l'espoir à travers la
poésie et de de redonner de redonner
toute sa dignité à ce grand peuple grec
qui a inventé la Démocratie et on
voudrait pas que que la Grèce devienne
le l'inseul de cette démocratie qu'elle
a inventé voilà donc un spectacle
musical d'une très très belle qualité
trèsentraînant aussi oui oui c'est une
très belle musique la musique gre ça
donne envie de danser il y a un côté
politique et peut-être un peu de
prophétie de C de ces poètes mais ça
reste très dynamique je vous propose
justement qu' qu'on écoute un
extrait
in
IR
donc c'était donc un extrait du
spectacle et les rêves prendront leur
revanche et qui clôturent donc la J
journée du samedi de samedi là le 22
mars donc à la ferme de bébaas où les
poètes sont donc portés à la scène merci
Yan Lavabre merci donc surtout n'hésitez
pas voilà les coordonnées s'affichent
pour appeler pour réserver voilà tout
tout est indiqué alors maintenant nous
on va continuer toujours dans le 16e
Printemps des Poètes mais également à
l'occasion de la 4e édition du temps des
femmes organisé donc par la ville de
guillancour puisque samedi 29 mars à la
batterie euh la chanteuse gazandie sera
donc présente dans le cadre d'un cabaret
poellitique suivi d'un concert et
Nicolas Gervet nous la
présente son nom signifie celle qui évit
les consciences en lingala et elle
propose une musique inclassable et
métissée qui lui a value le prix de
l'Académie charlescro pour son album
sorti en avril 2013 elle sera un concert
notamment le 29 mars à la batterie à
guyencour dans le cadre du Printemps des
poèmes et du temps des femmes de la
ville de guyencour Voici gazenji dans le
kiosque avant j'étais j'ai fait une
carrière de danseuse où j'ai dansé
derrière beaucoup d'autres artistes
comme MC solar princesse Erica
et donc arrivé à un moment l'expression
de de mon de mon art n'était plus
suffisant et j'arrivais pas à trouver
aussi les l'émotion dans la danse donc
j'ai cherché ailleurs comme moi je je je
chante dans plusieurs langues et les
langues ne sont pas forcément
compréhensible tout de suite et je crois
que la mélodie devienne langue du coup
et je je dis toujours que quand j'écris
une histoire et quand je la propose elle
devient l'histoire des autres devient
plus la
mienne on a beaucoup tourné sans même
sortir l'album physiquement et enfin il
est là avec retourner encore pour
l'année 2014 donc c'est que des
bénédictions en fait c'est un miracle
parce qu'à un moment donné je je crois
qu'il y a des artistes qui ont attendu
beaucoup plus longtemps pour sortir un
premier album mais moi ça fait 10 ans
que je suis sur la route que je joue
j'ai pas sorti d'album vraiment et
quelque part je n'y pensais plus parce
que pour moi le le le tout tout tout
tout ce tout l'art que je que j'ai envie
de développer ça se met vraiment ça se
montre vraiment sur sur scène ça vit sur
scène
je voulais faire un projet sur le rythme
parce que c'est c'est ça c'est ça mes
mes racines j'ai vraiment des racines
africaines où le rythme est vraiment
très important et la guitare je
commençais à apprendre un petit peu la
guitare ça me permettait de faire des
mélodies et la voix j'avais trois trois
trois instruments comme ça devant moi il
fallait que je me serve que de ce que je
savais ça grandit vraiment au fur à
mesure des rencontres je raconte donc
l'histoire de mon
père les trois cassettes que j'ai piqué
avant de venir de venir en France quand
il m'a envoyé toute seul avec ma ma
petite valise auprès saint-gervervais et
en fait l'histoire de gassanji commence
là
les premières choses que j'ai écouté
sans sans me dire j'allais faire de la
musique et c'est des choses qui qui
m'ont suivi et je crois que ça me suit
encore même inconsciemment aujourd'hui
il y avait George mustouaki il y avait
donc chanson française pure il y avait
autis reading donc soul américaine
laumba congolaise avec taboulet rochero
moi j'ai grandi vraiment avec avec ce
mélange là première chanson que j'ai
chanté je me rappelle plus quel âge
j'avais je crois j'avais même pas l'âge
de parler c'était no woman no cry de de
Bob Marley et voilà ça m'est resté aussi
dans le dans la tête
quoiing voilà voilà je je l'avais
traduite autrement je disais yo bomoka
c'est ve dire toi tu le
serpent
je peux pas dire bon là je m'assois je
vais écrire en lingala et
malheureusement l'inspiration ça vient
pas comme ça ça ça part d'un mot ça part
d'une phrase si elle commence en lingala
et ben ça va être en lingala et si elle
commence en français ce qui arrive aussi
donc ça va être en français il y a
vraiment des histoires ou des sentiments
que je j'exprime beaucoup plus
facilement en français parce que je
trouve les mots et que d'autres où je
vais vraiment plus avoir de facilité à
m'exprimer en
lingala
chez nous la musique sert à à à à mettre
nos morts sous terre à à pleurer voilà à
pleurer aller pleurer justement et on
avait jamais vu même à l'époque où mon
père où mon père vivait où il
m'expliquait un petit peu comment ça se
passait dans son village que les gens
viennent et puis font de la musique et
gagnent de l'argent avec c'est c'est
autre chose là on on arrive à autre part
donc moi quand j'ai commencé à faire de
la musique non seulement il était hors
de question de faire la musique parce
que comment tu fais pour gagner ta vie
quand tu fais de la musique c'est
complètement incertain c'est c'est juste
la la folie pure donc c'était pas du
tout il était pas question de faire ça
et puis il y av il y a pas cette culture
de dire ok je vais faire de la musique
et je vais aller gagner de l'argent avec
c'est aussi un problème de génération je
crois on est dans une nouvelle ère et
les choses évoluent et moi je respecte
vraiment beaucoup d'où je viens ma
culture et j'essaie juste de pas faire
des
sacrilèges par rapport
la musique quoi et voilà pour gazonji et
maintenant on retrouve Aurélia sur le
plateau du
kiosque France Miniature organisé
dimanche dernier une animation autour de
la maquette arien 5 en présence d'un
expert de l'industrie spatiale retour
sur cet après-midi de découverte de
l'espace près de 450 kg de résine et
1500 heur de travail auront été
nécessaire à la fabrication de la fusée
arienne 5 inaugurée en 2011 à France
Miniature car oui il s'agit bien d'une
reproduction au 1 20e cette maquette de
plus de 2 M60 était à l'honneur ce
dimanche pour une animation découverte
de l'espace au programme un quiz pour
évaluer ses connaissances et la
rencontre avec un expert spécialement
accueilli par le parc touristique pour
l'événement tout le monde est F est
fasciné par l'espace Jean-Luc Pasquier
est là aujourd'hui pour pour répondre à
toutes ces questions Arian 5
comment comment elle a été créée et
pourquoi et il apporte un peu plus de
précision sur l'espace maintenant je
voulais parler un peu de la Station
spatiale internationale est-ce que vous
connaissez oui dans gravity et ben on en
parle dans gravity absolument c'est une
bonne façon de connaître l'espace même
si tout n'est pas parfait dans gravity
il y a ici une magnifique maquette de
Arian 5 c'est c'est toujours une fusée
qui est importante pour pour l'Europe et
pour notre société puisque on est on en
est le fabricant elle est bien plus
petite que la vraie Ariane mais elle est
très
représentative dans dans dans tous ces
aspects hein on explique aussi ben les
les différents trop les utilisations des
satellites le fait que il y en a qui
sont en orbite très très basse et qui
servent par exemple à faire des photos
dans d'autres en orbite un peu moyenne
par exemple qui servent à la navigation
et puis d'autres sur la fameuse orbites
géostationnaires qui sont juste
au-dessus de l'équateur et qui servent
essentiellement pour les
télécommunications mission accomplie
après décryptage tout semble plus clair
pour ces jeunes visiteurs j'ai découvert
où se lancai les fusées comment été
fabriquer les fusé comment ça décollait
euh où ça a été lancé pardon voilà les
animations sont sans supplément au prix
d'entrée du parc prochaine date à
retenir le weekend de pâqu ou le
chocolat sera bien entendu à la
fête alors ce soir démarre la 18e
édition du festival de r enc festival
d'humour où neuf artistes sont en
compétition une occasion de découvrir
les nouveaux talents du rire donc de
demain à l'instar de Julie Ferrier
Olivier deenois ou encore Jean-Luc
Lemoine eux aussi repérés à rocencours
Éric bouverron le directeur artistique
était sur le sur le plateau pardon du 78
lactu on l'écoute pour connaître les
enjeux de ce festival il faut imaginer
ces trois soires de spectacle de
festivité avec ces artistes qui jouent
pour gagner un peu le piolet d'or qui
est le le trophée il joue aussi pour
gagner un peu de sous parce que c'est un
des rares festival où il y a des
sponsors qui met de l'argent pour les
gagnants mais c'est surtout un festival
pour encourager les les talents que ce
soit jeunes ou des gens confirmés c'est
un type de du festival d'humour comme on
peut dire le festival de cinéma à Cannes
donc on essaie de vraiment encourager ça
et découvrir un peu des des nouveaux
talents et des talents qu'on connaît pas
du
tout artiste distingués donc à cours se
produiront pour la soirée de gala du
festival le 29 avril au Théâtre
montancier à Versailles alors comme nous
sommes mercredi et bien maintenant c'est
l'heure des sortis ciné au micro d'é
lodim
moine un super film un film qui donne
envie d'avoir des potes
d'aimer des jolis Paris sur la
réalisation voilà un beau moment
sensationnel quoi voilà on a vraiment
aimé et
c'était avec mon ami on s'est tapé
vraiment des bonnes barordes de rire et
en même temps la situation euh moi
j'étais très sensible à ça parce que ça
m' arrivé de me retrouver un peu dans
cette situation là et c'est vraiment pas
agréable à vivre très bon film très
bonne comédie française qu'on a pas
l'habitude de de voir avec un grand
manupiller à la fois réalisateur et et
et acteur dans le film vraiment je
recommande à tout le monde d'Er voir on
passe un super moment on rigole bien et
eu super comédie romantique vraiment à
l'américaine très bon moment original
j'ai beaucoup aimé film très intelligent
et puis bon la voix de Scarlet Johnson
en off je trouve ça
assez assez assez excitant et assez joli
un film intéressant que j'ai beaucoup
aimé un très bon film c'est ce n'est
enfin la réalisation n'est pas
sublimeisse mais surtout le scénario
était magnifique très bons acteurs et
c'était vraiment génial un conseil à
voir absolument alors cette semaine
notre professionnel du cinéma et Gael
Pino responsable du grenier à celle à
trappe qui nous donne son coup de cœur
mon coup de cœur cette semaine c'est un
film que l'on va présenter le mercredi
26 mars à
20h45 c'est un une séance hors les murs
c'est un peu un petit événement c'est
une séance donc hors les murs du
Festival International de film
documentaire qui s'appelle cinéma du
réel c'est organisé par le le Centre
Pompidou à Paris et plus précisément par
la Bibliothèque publique d'information
du Centre Pompidou et dans ce cadre là
donc nous allons projeter le film Go
force ça sera une projection inédite et
le réalisateur viendra le présenter
gofce ça veut dire aller de l'avant
c'est réalisé par Soufian Adel c'est
donc lui qui viendra et c'est donc un
documentaire il parle de il a rencontré
il a interviewé sa grand-mère qui a 79
ans qui habite dans une banlieu
parisienne elle parle d'elle pendant la
Guer d'Indochine puis de la guerre
d'Algérie et de son divorce et ENF de
son arrivée en France et c'est c'est un
peu son histoire personnelle à elle de
de la grand-mère de sa famille prise
dans l'histoire collective la grande
histoire avec un grand H ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on on a un retour
critique sur le passé colonial mais on a
aussi une vision inédite sur sur la
banlieue et c'est plutôt plutôt positif
on sort des images des discours
habituels on sort des clichés et et on
on sent comme une repossession de la
cité avec un grand C et une repossession
de l'Histoire avec un grand H c'est
peut-être ça que veut dire le titre Go
force aller de l'avant et donc ce sera
mercredi 26 mars à 20h45 et c'est entrée
libre alors je vous propose à présent
d'autres idées de sortie ces prochains
jours alors tout d'abord une soirée pour
fêter la Saint-Patrick alors la
Saint-Patrick c'était lundi donc c'est
un peu en retard mais c'est toujours
l'occasion d'un concert tridaft Monke
donc ce sera vendredi 21 mars à 20h30 au
scarabé à La Verrière ambiance folk
celtique alors tout autre ambiance celle
du carnaval où la compagnie d'ifekaco
fêtera le printemps dans les rues de
trappe avec un défilé donc carnavalesque
et un bal concert samedi à 16h vous
pourrez également assister au premier
match d'improvisation de la saison les
équipes des benjamins cadet et junior se
retrouveront samedi 22 mars à 14h30 16h
et 20h à école de musique et de danse de
trappe voilà notre émission est à
présent terminée merci de nous avoir
suivi sur TVfil je vous retrouve donc la
semaine prochaine en direct à 18h30 à
mercredi